all right we decided to do a
walk-through video today where we put
some audio over
the level while we play
it is
level 70 this is a level that most
people have been getting stuck on lately
and um
thought this might help to get people
through
first thing you need to do is clear the
ice
you see the different colors that are
frozen there we're going to start off
with an l because those are always good
it's at the bottom of the board
so that's also helpful because a lot of
other things happen as a result
um
in the beginning you don't really have a
lot of choices so you just want to pick
the move that's going to make the most
well basically that's going to clear the
ice the fastest
like i said in the beginning you really
don't have a lot of options so you just
we do have one red pepper that's free
now but there's not enough other red
peppers out there to like explode it
but that one did actually clear out the
other red that was in the ice
one of the things that's hard about this
level is that it you know it's 15 moves
and you get close a lot and you get it's
easy to get frustrated so you you want
to make sure that you're
thinking about why you make each move
it's really
we really like this level actually but
um
obviously we've played it a lot of times
um the
the thing about it is you're not really
going to get lucky when you're playing
this and just accidentally finish the
level it's it's not that kind of a level
so
you have to look for situations where
you can um actually set some moves up
if you read the guide you know that
we talk about
setting up the
t's and the l's and the four pepper
matches
um
right now you can see we have the two
green above this one
that would uh could make the uh
shockwave so
that's something to look for
you know but we also still want to clear
the ice so
we're just going to continue growing
peppers and see what what
pops up what we can um
work with
now that that's that's a spot where we
can we're definitely going to make a
vertical match so we can
directly make the shock wave those are
the ones you want to look for all the
time when you see you have two color two
peppers of the same color next to a
statue
you want to see if there's any possible
way that you can bring one down
and
create the shock wave
here you can see we have yellow sitting
next to four of the statues
there's not a lot of yellow in the
middle though so i don't know if we can
grow those
there's another one
so we definitely take that
hit as soon as it as soon as it comes up
so now all the ice is clear that statue
is gone
oranges
they're more orange than anything else
next to the statues but the it's not
really in a position where we can
actually
get anything going with it at the moment
so
here i'll match the yellow
because that puts a stage five pepper
right next to the statue that's already
damaged
so now if we explode
a green pepper it'll it'll cause a hit
to that one
this will start a
that'll give us that hit and we might
get the one at the top we got the green
so that's good
it doesn't look like we're going to get
the other yellow one but that's fine
all right so we got a shock wave at the
top that's good
we have two red ones at the top on the
left
so we'll just see if we can't move
something down there's nothing really in
this column so
if we move this one it'll move the red
next to it
but it'll also match the red at the top
and that did the same thing so that
wasn't necessarily a good move
but there are times when you just don't
really have a good move in this level
that worked out
now we don't have any
any shock waves that we can set up
and we have
orange by two of the statues
the rest are all mixed up
here we can make that orange match the
top but it's not really going to lead to
a shockwave like to an explosion i mean
or a chain reaction so i think clearing
out this column would be better
see what falls
see how things end up
same thing here i mean
we're getting closer to be able to
explode the orange but dropping peppers
is never a bad thing and
the only thing unfortunately that
happens sometimes as we
start a pepper panic when we don't
really need it
and again we got a kind of a bad drop
here where we don't have
any any shockwave matches to set up
we haven't used half of our moves yet
though so we're doing pretty good
exploding red would be the the best
color it looks like we
might be able to get in there so
we'll just
work on that for now and see what
happens
and we do have one like one green next
to the statue so
and one orange
two orange actually so orange isn't so
bad
still would kind of like to match the
red though
the match at the top like it might
get us two hits if it
i don't think it well let's see
there's not really a better move let's
put it that way
okay yeah so it did that's fine
it looks like the one on the bottom
right is going to be the hardest one for
us to get
well we almost had a a t right there but
all right so
now we have the two right here by this
statue and the gap's already in place
but
we could match the yellow
in that row
but it won't drop it as far as we need
it to go
now this is interesting because look we
have two five
pepper matches that we can make
but i think it's better to skip it
because we can definitely hit the hit
the one on the left with the orange if
we drop the uh if we just make a regular
three pepper match like that
and one of the reasons for clearing the
other row is because we still have those
two red sitting there so
we can try to bring the other reds down
but the uh
all right so now we're back to where we
started from we don't have anything
sitting right next to
a statue that we can
work um
matching the greens fine because we
that's next to one of the big statues
the red obviously is slightly better but
it wasn't available and when you could
start a pepper panic quick and you don't
you're not losing any like um big
peppers
then it's fine to do that
and so now we're
at 17 moves when we have
we don't have
a good setup but we do have um
plenty of moves to try to set something
up
yeah just growing the red will probably
be
the best way to go at this point
if we here we make this for pepper we'll
actually make a um you know get those
two red ones together
and it didn't work out but that that's
still the way you you kind of want to
think about it it's
it's pretty hard to figure out where
they're gonna actually end up you can
only just
you know
do what looks like it'll work out the
best
most of the
time we're a little bit stuck now so
we're just sort of moving things
we have these two orange here with the
orange above but there's really no way
to drop
anything below it so what
what we do there is we're hoping that we
could drop a red in because any color
could fall there
we didn't get it we got yellow instead
but
that would have been
you know helpful if we had another red
one there and we are able to
start a train reaction with the red
that's kind of an awkward spot because
we didn't make it and now they're all
far away from each other so
probably gonna have to just move things
around again and see what happens
obviously we won't be mad if the yellow
go here but it's unlikely
we got the red
all right so this is really like where
this level ends up most of the time we
need two hits and we have eight moves
so this is where you have to like even
though it's been long and you've been
like you can see if i match these green
at the bottom
after i match those
now the orange one is going to fall
where i want it's going to bring that
one down
and it's going to have the yellow to
where i can match them
to drop the orange one into place to
start the first shock wave so
match the green first
and then match the yellow
see how this will drop in and then
that's one of our hits
now
the green is right there but we can't
get to it
what we can do is we can make the shock
wave with the green up top
and hit those two and they'll explode
and move out of the way at least
because they're both stage five they're
both like steaming or whatever and
they're ready to explode
and
oh
that was almost good
now we'll just drop another one down and
see what happens i mean we
there's not a clear-cut best
thing to do here we matching those
greens at the top there really isn't
gonna
like with four moves we're not gonna be
able to actually blow that up normally
so
again here it's like
i think we go with the shock wave again
because it'll grow the two green ones
below and it may set off something above
that would
give us
to where we're close to exploding that
statue
can't match the green first because then
we'll lose our our shock wave going down
so we have to make that one first
hope for the best
well they get a green match yeah
and that's how you do it you um
you just plan out your moves and do the
best you can then
sometimes it takes a little bit of help
from the peppers but um you can you can
beat it like you said we do like this
level because it can
you do have control it's not based
completely on luck you know and
um we're sure that you can beat it too
you just have to take your time and find
those moves
um
make sure you take a second to like us
on facebook there's a the like buttons
on the right hand side that'll give you
updates and check back regularly we're
always adding new content
thanks for
checking out our video and hopefully
it'll help you get through the level
have a good one
you